BRIAN DORSEY: This is importing
large data sets into
Google Cloud Storage.
You're in the right room, and
thank you for coming or
watching on video.
My name is Brian Dorsey, and
I'm a developer programs
engineer in developer relations
on Google Cloud.
DAVE BARTH: I'm Dave Barth.
I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud Storage.
BRIAN DORSEY: And let's
get started.
So very quickly we're going to
go through a tiny bit of
background.
We're going to run through
progressively larger size and
scale imports.
And then, talk a little bit
about how to post process your
data, and how to integrate it
with your application, and
some tips and tricks for all
scales of data imports, a
special announcement, and
then, your questions.
So let's get started.
I expect that being this is an
importing talk, many of you
are already familiar with Google
Cloud Storage, but I'm
just going to run through a
few things quickly to make
sure we're all coming
from the same place.
This is a whole lot of words,
but to summarize, Google Cloud
Storage has a ton of features.
It is basically a container for
your data that lives in
Google infrastructure and
communicates on the
internet via HTTP.
And we have a bunch of features
to make that HTTP
communication very efficient
and easy to use, but that's
the main part of it.
It's also a project that is
under very active development.
Just in the last year, we've
released a whole bunch of
features on the bottom there,
which could be an entire talk
in and of itself, but that's
not this talk.
We're talking about
importing data.
But I wanted to take a quick
moment and reflect on the
awesome that is Google
Cloud Storage.
I think all of you have used
applications and most of you
have probably built applications
that store their
data in files.
Right?
And that works out
pretty well.
It's easy to get started.
And at some point, you need
another disk and then, another
disk and another disk.
And at some point, you need
another machine because you
filled that machine up, and you
start adding more machines
and a little complexity
here and there.
And then, you decide you need
the data somewhere else or
maybe you need another copy
of it for redundancy.
So that adds some complexity,
and it just keeps going.
So at some point, you end up
with this gnarly knot of
interconnected pieces on your
architectural diagram.
And you're probably familiar
with the steps to get you from
one place to the other.
You've done it enough times as
you hit those levels, you know
how to address that.
But each time you do that,
that's an interruption from
taking you away from building
features for your users.
And we really think of Google
Cloud Storage as a way to
trade that knot for a hosted
service from Google.
And with a little bit of work
integrating the APIs on your
part, you get to take advantage
of the scale of the
Google Cloud Platform and all
of the redundancy speed that
we provide through the system.
It is a solution where you're
not going to have to worry
about the scale.
We have developers who have
literally billions of objects
in a single bucket and
developers with multiple
petabytes of data in a bucket.
We're ready to take your data
and run with it and help you
make your applications
amazing.
And it's also very close to the
rest of the Google Cloud
Platform, so it becomes a great
gateway to all the other
work you might want to do in
BigQuery, Compute Engine, App
Engine, and the like.
We make that very easy.
So let's move on to
smaller imports.
These are things on the few
gigabyte scale or tens or
hundreds of files.
And in some ways, it's an excuse
to talk about gsutil.
So just a quick question.
How many people in the room
have heard of gsutil?
And how many people have
actually used it?
OK.
Awesome.
So quick demo just to give
you a sense of gsutil.
I've got a directory here that's
living, actually, on a
Compute Engine instance because
I want a pixel.
And I've got some files here
that I would like to copy up
into Google Cloud Storage.
So I can say, gsutil cp data
star to GS some bucket name,
and we're going to use I/O demo
as the bucket name, and
it copies one file.
But I actually meant to
copy all of these.
And one of the things I'd like
to highlight here is gsutil
tries very hard to
help you out.
And it says, oh, did you
actually mean to do a
recursive copy there?
Perhaps you wanted the dash
capital R. And in fact, I did.
So let's go ahead and do that.
And then, we've now copied all
of that data up into Google
Cloud Storage, and it's
available from anywhere.
Cloud Storage also fairly
uniquely offers
read-after-write consistency.
So as soon as you get the OK
back, they're available to the
whole world.
Exactly that version.
Quickly, we can go ahead and run
an LS command on this same
bucket, and we should see
a different result here.
Look at that.
We've got some data up there.
Another way to look at the same
data is in the Google
Cloud Counsel.
This is our new UI for
the various Google
Cloud Platform APIs.
And the Cloud Storage version
of this was, in fact, just
released last week.
So I encourage you to
take a look at that.
If we come down here and switch
back and forth between
the buckets, we can see
the same thing there.
So you can go ahead and work
through the web UI as well.
So in a way, this talk is going
to be a little bit of a
love song four gsutil.
Here's how you get it.
The tried and true way is go
ahead and download a zip or
tarball and extract that out,
and you're good to go.
We've also just started a
developer preview of the
Google Cloud SDK, and that is
a collection of tools for
Cloud Storage, Compute Engine,
BigQuery, App Engine, all
bundled together in one download
and install with
consistent auth.
So you do the authorization
once, and it works
across all the tools.
We've also, for Python
programmers, gsutil
is written in Python.
It's open source up on GitHub,
and it is mostly based at the
lower levels on top of
the boto library for
communicating.
And if you're a Python developer
or you're working in
a Python stack, it might
make sense to
you to use pip install.
And we've got an experimental
release where you
can do that as well.
One of the key things gsutil
provides is a conceptual path
abstraction.
The Cloud Storage itself
is a flat name
space within a bucket.
So you can have as many
names as you want,
but it's a flat space.
It is not actually aware
of hierarchy.
But gsutil goes and tries to
give you a sense of hierarchy
because you're usually going
back and forth between file
systems and the cloud, and it
just makes it easier to say I
want to copy a subdirectory
here, and that sort of thing.
So it tries very hard to give
you commands that look like
the regular Unix commands you're
used to with a couple
exceptions around buckets
and the like.
It also provides complete
feature
support for the product.
So Google Cloud Storage
has many features
that are very useful.
For example, hosting
static websites
directly from Cloud Storage.
And you can configure those
features through extensions.
Gsutil provides those.
And for smaller data sets, we
can go ahead and just do a
straight cp, and
that's plenty.
It works out great.
Here's some example command
lines of going back and forth
between text files and Google
Cloud Storage, back down.
It also, since it's based on the
boto library, it inherits
the ability to talk
to Amazon S3.
So you can use gsutil to
talk to S3 if you're
already using S3.
And you can also copy back and
forth between S3 and Google
Cloud Storage.
Those copies do go through
the machine that
you run gsutil on.
So be aware that.
And also, just as a thought to
put in your head, gsutil is
essentially a reference to how
to make good applications.
Talk to Google Cloud Storage.
It's a reference implementation
of efficiently
communicating with
Cloud Storage.
And if you just go ahead and
do a straight gsutil cp,
what's the first limit you're
going to run into?
And I predict it will
be network latency.
By default, gsutil does
one thing at a time.
So if you've got 100 files or
1,000 files, no matter what
size they are, it does
a round trip.
Or in some cases, a couple back
and forth to the service,
and all of those run
sequentially.
So you can end up taking a
lot of time to do that.
So what do we do about that?
Let's do some larger imports.
This is things in the tens of
gigabytes, perhaps the tens of
terabytes, very large numbers
of files in the hundreds of
thousands, in that
sort of range.
We just add this dash m and
it's all good, right?
That's easy.
We're done.
So the dash m stands for
multi-processing and
multi-threading, and gsutil
actually uses both at the same
time to maximize overall
throughput.
And since it's I/O, if you end
up needing to, you can dive in
to the dot boto configuration
file, and there's various
things to control gsutil
operation in there.
But related to this, you could
actually tweak the number of
processes and threads
if you need to.
Most the time, it does a very
good job of defaults.
So that was kind of like, look,
I just hand wave, and
it's all fast, right?
So what kind of limitations
are you going to run into
after adding the
magical dash m?
You're going to run into network
bandwidth this time is
probably the case.
So Google Cloud Storage is
hosted on Google networks,
Google infrastructure, and
Google Storage technology.
So you're running over the same
networks that we use to
host YouTube, and Gmail, and
all of the things they may
have talked about in other
sessions where internet
requests go quickly from most
users ISPs directly onto
Google backbone.
And that communicates on the
Google internal network.
You get all of those
advantages.
One side effect of that is just
gsutil dash m can often
completely saturate your upload
bandwidth all by itself.
So in many cases, you can go
with the absolute fastest that
your internet connection
can sustain.
Many of you, however, have very
fast networks, and you
may first run into disk I/0
as your bottleneck.
So if you're copying everything
from one drive, and
you copy a whole bunch of
different files, you get a
bunch of random seeks.
And things can end up slowing
down that way.
So you can end up wanting to
use multiple machines to
speed things up.
And then, once you get enough
files, there ends up being
coordination and complexity
challenges just in terms of
keeping track of which files
need to be copied, which ones
to copy next, perhaps, how to
figure out which machines to
copy them from, and that
sort of thing.
So there's one other
situation that I
wanted to call out here.
So the way dash m makes things
faster is by doing more things
at the same time.
So it's running multiple
copies.
But what if you really have a
single large file that you're
trying to speed up?
Can't use dash m, right?
Or can we?
So what you can do is you can
actually split your file into
multiple pieces and upload
those in parallel and ask
Google Cloud Storage
to reassemble them
back into one object.
And this uses the compose
feature that was released a
few months ago.
And it works very, very well,
and especially in situations
where your data naturally comes
from multiple sources.
For example, the output of
MapReduce jobs or some sort of
logging and you actually want
to combine them all into one
logical object in the end, it
can be very convenient to
upload them all separately
and combine them
actually in the cloud.
One limitation I'd like to
mention there, is the compose
is currently limited
to 32 pieces.
So you can take 32 objects and
combine them into one.
So now, we get into
enormous imports.
Really?
Is it that easy?
And we just had a customer go
through this process with
great success, and I'd like to
hand this over to Dave to talk
about that.
DAVE BARTH: Thank you.
So I'd like to walk you through
a recent example of a
customer that needed to move 5,
over 5 petabytes, actually,
into Google Cloud Storage.
And before I dive into that,
sometimes we throw these big
numbers around.
I'd just like to recognize that
5 petabytes is actually a
lot of data.
You could burn 5 petabytes of
data to just over 100,000
Blu-ray DVDs or you can stick
that on your TV and watch 100
years of high definition video
if you were so inclined.
So this is actually a pretty
significant migration that
this customer went through.
And this is the architecture
of the system that was put
together for that migration.
It obviously is a little
bit more complicated
than gsutil dash m.
But I want to point out that the
actual work that's being
done, the migration work, or the
red boxes in this diagram,
that really is gsutil dash
m running across in this
instance multiple Compute
Engine machines.
So what's the rest of it?
Well, the rest of it is that
coordination complexity that
Brian mentioned that you're
going to end up having to deal
with if you do really
large migrations.
In this case, there's
two parts to it.
So breaking it down, there's
basically coordinating the
migration in order to set up the
objects that are going to
get copied by these Compute
Engine instances, doing the
copying, and then validating
and cleaning
up after the copying.
For the coordination, that was
done with an App Engine app.
Oh, I should've mentioned.
I forgot to mention that this
customer is actually moving
his data from Amazon S3 over
to Google Cloud Storage.
So they had requirements to.
Of course, they wanted to move
it as quickly as possible.
They also wanted to do a live
migration and delete the
objects off of S3 as they were
being copied over to Cloud
Storage so that they didn't
end up double paying for 5
petabytes of data right
up to the very end.
And so the first thing that they
did in order to queue up
which objects needed to be
copied and coordinate the
transfer was, there's an App
Engine app that basically just
listed all the objects that
needed to be transferred out
of the customer's S3 bucket.
So they just get a list of
object names, and they would
queue those up into an App
Engine task queue, which is
just a standard component that
any App Engine developer can
make use of.
So there's all these object's
names that are sitting in the
task queues, and that's
basically all the
coordination, all the prep, that
was required before the
copying began.
The copying itself is basically
firing up a bunch of
Compute Engine instances.
Each Compute Instance would pull
a handful of objects off
of the task queue, and then
use gsutil dash m to copy
those over to Cloud Storage.
I think there are at peak
about 160 Compute Engine
instances running in parallel
at any given time.
And that basically handled
the copying aspect of it.
Now, the post processing
validation.
So what was done in this
particular case was, every
time an object completed its
copying, a note was made into
what's noted here as the
migration bucket, which is
just a separate Google Cloud
Storage bucket that
essentially held a series
of flat files.
With each Compute Engine
instance, every time we'd
finished copying something,
we'd just append a note
saying, this object was copied,
and this was the hash
code that was returned from
Google Cloud Storage.
And that enabled the customer's
systems then to go
back and read through that list
of objects that was in
the migration bucket, check that
the hash code matched to
make sure there wasn't any
corruption during the copying,
update the index in their client
system so that the end
user computer knew that if it
wanted that object it now
could find it over on Google
Cloud Storage instead of on
Amazon S3, and then go and
delete the object from S3.
So overall, everybody was really
pleased with how the
migration went.
I forgot to mention, it was
about four billion objects.
It was significantly over 5
petabytes of data, but there
was a period of set up
and testing of the
system I just described.
And then, once it got humming,
the bulk of the data, about 5
petabytes, was moved
in five weeks.
So it was about an average of
12 gigabytes per second
throughput, and it regularly
peaked above 20
gigabytes per second.
And perhaps most important,
there wasn't any down time in
the client application.
And so this addressed a lot
of the limits that Brian
mentioned before.
Network bandwidth, of course,
wasn't really a problem by
virtue of the data being moved
from S3 over to Cloud Storage.
Google has quite sufficient
peering, network
peering, with Amazon.
So that wasn't an issue.
In this particular case, disk
I/O also wasn't an issue,
because we were moving from
another cloud provider that
had a lot of scale.
It also helped, we didn't really
worry about it much in
any case, because the customer's
objects, their
object names were all
hashes themselves.
So it was really, really easy
to partition the data.
Speaking of partitioning, if
you're moving from an on
premise system then, that's
where coordination can come in
really handy.
You know how your data is
stored, and you can, during
the coordination step, basically
make sure that you
partition it and shard it up
so that each Compute Engine
instance that's handling or
whatever instance is handling
the copy in parallel, is working
on different bits of
data at a time so no particular
disk gets too hot.
And the coordination and
complexity was handled, of
course, by building up some
of these components on the
coordination side to the App
Engine instance in order to
queue objects to be copied.
And then, this post processing
step where the client
application was updated to know
where to find the object,
post processing is going to be
something that's going to tend
to be pretty client specific,
use case specific.
But also really, really
important.
So Brian's going to talk a
little bit more about that.
BRIAN DORSEY: Thanks a lot.
Thanks Dave.
OK.
So now, you've got all this
data in your Google Cloud
Storage buckets.
And presumably, you guys have
written some amazing
applications that delight
your users.
So we want to allow you to
easily make Cloud Storage the
processes there become part
of your application.
So if you need to transcode the
data after upload, if you
need to make thumbnails, if you
apply your special sauce,
you can do that easily
and very quickly.
So this is a big wall of detail,
JSON details here.
But essentially, we offer a
feature called notifications,
and you enable notifications
on the bucket level.
And once you've enabled it,
every single change that is
made to that bucket, every new
upload, every over write,
every delete, every metadata
change, turns into, in
addition to actually saving
the data and making the
change, turns into an HTTP post
to any URL you choose.
So what you get is details about
the change that just
happened over HTTP
to your app.
So that can be an
App Engine app.
It can be an app that you host
anywhere, and very soon after
the actual change happens,
you'll find out about it.
So there's no need to write a
bunch of polling logic, and
that sort of thing.
It can become more tightly
integrated with your
application workflow.
And this kind of
handler doesn't
need to be very complex.
You can accept the post, do a
little dispatch on what type
of event it is, and then pull
out the information you care
about, buckets, names,
what have you.
And then, do whatever
you need to do.
So at this point, you could
put it in a database.
You could put it in a queuing
system, anything that you
could imagine.
Once it's in a database or a
queue, as app developers, the
sky's the limit, right?
You can go from there and
do anything you need.
So it's a quick and easy way
to get tight integration
between Cloud Storage and the
rest of your application, make
it feel more seamless.
There's another situation that
can arise where you need to do
bulk changes.
So part of the way that Cloud
storage, Google Cloud Storage,
achieves scalability is access
control is to find it at an
individual object level.
So every single object
has access control.
So the rights of who's allowed
to read, who's allowed to
write it, change it,
that sort of thing.
And if you change your mind
about how that should be
later, you may need to
do a bulk update
against all of the objects.
As an aside, we recommend that
you use groups for often
changing group membership.
So you can do that independently
of this.
But if you make a large scale
change to your access control,
you may run into some challenges
because you
actually need to do a request
response cycle per object.
Or perhaps, if you're doing a
large migration or conversion
of some sort, you might have a
staging bucket that you might
need to clear out that
has a lot of objects.
And one approach
that you can--
in most cases, I recommend going
ahead and just using
gsutil dash m rm for remove or
we have a command CH ACL for
changing ACLs, and that
will cover you in the
vast majority of cases.
But if you start to get into
half a million, a million,
couple million objects, here's
something to look at.
The new JSON API, Google Cloud
Storage JSON API, supports
batching of requests.
So what would normally have
been a round trip actually
becomes one round trip, split
apart on the other end, and
then you get all the responses
back in a batch as well.
So you can make batches of 1,000
or more requests and
responses in one network call.
And those all get sent
off to Cloud Storage.
This is just kind of a rough
idea of what that looks like
on the wire, but logically it
groups the requests, multiple
requests into one.
In terms of how you would
actually write this code in
Python, it's relatively
straightforward.
So we've got some set
up stuff here.
We're doing credentials at the
top, and that sort of thing.
But the meat of it is, we've got
a list of things that we
want to apply a change to and
we iterate through them and
call this function, I'm going
to show on the next slide,
called batch remove.
And I'll have a URL to these
slides at the very end of the
deck, so all this
will be there.
And so we call batch remove
with our objects.
And batch remove, if we take a
look right here in the center,
this is a normal Python Client
Library call that we're just
wrapping in this batch system.
So we just add each of those
calls to the batch and then at
the end, execute the batch.
So it's pretty straightforward
to convert code that you
already have that is doing
it one at a time
into a batch call.
And that's what this would
end up looking like.
I know this is a few chunks, so
we've got an example up on
GitHub, a full example, of
using this technique.
And that's there.
And then, I'd like to go into
some tips and techniques that
work across any scale
data you've got.
So you've got a little bit of
data, you've got a lot of
data, a whole bunch of
different scenarios.
First off, I really highly
recommend taking a look at the
gsutil help.
So just as you'd expect, gsutil
help and many of you
are familiar with command line
applications and how obscure
their help can be and this,
that, the other, gsutil has--
let's go ahead and
do less here--
complete help--
or not--
complete help for all of the
regular commands, and it also
has at the end these special
topics like access control
lists or credentials or, my
favorite I think, is Prod.
If you are going to write
one of these, go
ahead and read this.
Each of these is like a little
essay in and of itself on best
practices for using
Google Cloud
Storage as part of gsutil.
So you can learn a lot about
the product and the best
practices by working
with gsutil help.
Highly recommend it.
Also, Dave mentioned it a bit
in passing, but one simple
technique you can use to address
the complexity for
medium sized workloads is to
split your work up by prefix.
And what that means is your
object names, you could have
them start with a certain
character.
Or if they already start with
certain alphabetic letters,
you can use that to
your advantage.
So for example, in this example,
the files you were
going to upload are already
MD5 hashes.
You have a natural, just by
starting at the first
character, you have a natural
split into 16 even groups.
And if you needed to 256 even
groups for some reason, you
could use the first two
characters and split them out
and run them separately.
Another way to think about
this is inverting it.
When you're designing your
workflow, if you're know
you're going to want to access
these objects by date, for
example, put the dates
up at the beginning
of the object names.
That makes it very easy to
separate them out and work
with them individually later.
And that way, you can get all of
the log files from the same
day and things like that.
Another thing that can come
up is this happens at
both ends the scale.
If you've got a set of objects
that you're manually trying to
work with and you want to do
operations or check them or
copy them over and over, or if
you want to have an external
program create the list of
things to work on, you can use
this dash uppercase
I flag for copy.
And in this case, I'm
using a text file in
and piping into gsutil.
But the actual source program
can be any program you write
or xargs or what have you
on the Unix side.
So you could work from a static
file or a dynamically
generated list of files and pipe
them directly through it
and still let gsutil do the
copying work for you.
So that can be pretty
powerful.
Another thing to remember is the
data is actually copying
through gsutil.
so you want to run the gsutil
app itself close, in a network
sense, to one end of
the connection.
So in the example Dave talked
about, the connection was
actually on Compute Engine so
that's in the Google Cloud so
that's very close to
Cloud Storage.
Or you may need to actually run
it on premise at your data
center, and that
may make sense.
So that actually only works if
you've got enough bandwidth.
We hinted at that.
So I'd like to hand
it off to Dave.
DAVE BARTH: Right
it only works if
you have enough bandwidth.
And we started with network
constrained, and you never get
rid of that.
If you have a poor internet
connection between your data
and Google, you're going to have
a bad time moving that
data to Google.
We're really happy, today,
to announce a
work around for that.
And that is, offline disk
import, which basically works
around the internet.
And that involves basically
writing your data to a disk
and shipping it to
us in Google to
upload from our network.
We don't necessarily recommend a
manila envelope, although, I
guess it might work
just as well.
The process is pretty
straightforward.
Format a SATA disk with encfs.
This encrypts the data.
So make sure that if it gets
lost, or protects it,
basically, during deranged
shipment.
Copy your data to the disk.
Mail it to Google.
We'll upload it to a Google
Cloud Storage bucket that's
owned by the customer.
We don't touch the
data at all.
We just upload it and make use
of Google's fast network, and
then ship the disk back.
We're launching this feature
in limited preview today.
Meaning that, you can sign up
at the link there to let us
know you're interested
in making use of it.
And we'll take applicants as
we can to scale it up.
Right now, it's only available
for customers that are located
in the United States.
If you're an international
customer, please do fill out
the interest form anyway and let
us know, because we will
be definitely expanding this
internationally in coming
months, and that may help us
prioritize a little bit.
And the prices is a
flat $80 per disk.
We don't charge any other fees
and that beyond the usual
storage fees that are associated
with any kind of
Google Cloud Storage usage.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
Thank you very much.
And I wanted to highlight a few
of the things that have
happened in the last year.
Several of these I've talked
about in the talk and a few of
them I haven't.
You can also enable versioning
on any bucket.
So as things change, you keep
the old versions around.
We announced Durable Reduced
Availability storage for
situations where backup, in
particular, where you're
willing to trade
a little bit of
availability for a lower price.
And we lowered prices by
30% in the last year.
And also throughout the talk,
if you were paying careful
attention, I did actually
reference several things that
have been announced recently.
So the Cloud Console
is one of them.
It was actually just
released last week.
We also talked about the Compose
Command which allows
you to combine multiple
objects in the cloud.
Notifications, which I
mentioned in the post
processing.
Our new JSON API that's been out
for many months but just
went through a significant
revision and improvement and
went to, the correct
term is, preview.
And that is now available, and
our intent is to make that a
generally available feature.
And so we highly recommend
you take a look at that.
It's very good, and offline
disk import.
So to wrap up a little bit,
we've talked about many tools
and techniques to help you
get your data into
Google Cloud Storage.
And Google Cloud Storage is a
very reliable, efficient,
fast, place to store
your data.
And we look forward to seeing
the applications that all of
you build on top of Google
Cloud Storage.
We'd like to move into Q&A. And
as we do that, I'd like to
invite two other folks up to
the stage from the Google
Cloud Storage team.
We have--
Yup.
Bring them up here.
And go ahead and line up
at the mics if you have
questions for us.
I'll let you guys introduce
yourself.
Hi.
I'm Lamia Youseff, and I'm the
BM on the Google Import Desk.
Hi.
I'm Bill [? Agos, ?]
and I'm the tech lead for
the Cloud Storage.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK.
First question.
AUDIENCE: With regards to
small and medium sized
uploads, is there a reason why
I would not want to use the
dash m If I want to get that
smaller amount in a
multi-thread fashion aside
from the limitations or
problems that were mentioned
with the large data
structures?
BRIAN DORSEY: No.
In most cases, you can use dash
m in almost any scenario.
So yeah.
Go ahead and use dash m.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work in the industrial
electronics sector, and we see
a lot of times people trying to
pull information from PLCs
or different types of servers so
that they can put into the
cloud for redundancy.
Do you see this edition of the
offline import being helpful
in that instance where they're
going to be trying to take
previous data and put into the
cloud so they can still have
that redundancy for previous
instances?
LAMIA YOUSEFF: I would say
definitely yes, since it's
going to be much faster to get
the data into the cloud.
However, if it's already online
and the size of the
data is not very large, then
maybe the online version is
going to be much faster.
So it depends on the
size of the data.
BRIAN DORSEY: It really comes
down to the amount of data you
have, and the bandwidth of your
network connection, and
how long you have before you
need the data online.
So if those don't work, Disk
Import becomes a great choice.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have any suggestions for
best practices on getting
data and logs out of App Engine
into the Cloud Storage?
BRIAN DORSEY: So I think for
that the very best thing to do
is to recommend visiting
the Cloud Sandbox.
We'll have some more App
Engine experts there.
But I will just hint that
there are some tools for
getting exports of the App
Engine Data Store directly
into Cloud Storage, and you can
also use all the regular
Cloud Storage APIs directly
from App Engine code.
AUDIENCE: Is there any way to
do streaming uploads or to
append a file without resorting
to combine?
I'm sorry, streaming
uploads doing what?
AUDIENCE: Streaming uploads or
appending some files that are
already uploaded.
BILL: Yes.
So you can't do an append right
now, forever and ever.
But what you can do is you can
use the object composition up
to a limit.
So if, for example, you're doing
logs and you want to
snapshot logs on an hourly
basis, you could
do that up to 32.
But other than that, the append
support, just general
append, it's not supported.
BRIAN DORSEY: And one work
around for that, resumable
uploads for a limited time
frame, you can actually leave
a resumable upload open, and
you can keep trickling the
upload up to the service.
But the objects only become
available once it's completed.
So if you need to use the data
in between, you have to use
composition.
AUDIENCE: How long
can that take?
What's the maximum time.
BRIAN DORSEY: About a week.
Try to keep it under a week.
AUDIENCE: Can say anything about
compression built-in
support with gsutil?
BILL:I don't think it does any
support encryption by default.
Encryption, I mean, compression
by default.
But you certainly go ahead
and gzip data.
Gzip it before you upload it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jeremy.
I work for Edit Share.
It's a company that does high
speed local storage for video
production.
BRIAN DORSEY: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: And we've considered
using Cloud services for some
of our customers, and even for
some of these customers who
are willing to just mail in a
disk and upload it to the
Cloud, one key feature, which
they require, is being able
to, essentially, get at parts
of that data quickly.
So how exactly would I do the
equivalent of a seek using and
just copying that
part of a file?
BILL: You can basically
use range gets.
So you can basically say, give
me the byte ranges that you
want out of the full object.
AUDIENCE: And is that something
I could do in
parallel for lots of objects.
BRIAN DORSEY: Absolutely.
HTTP range header.
And there's no more people up
there with questions, but
we'll just say that we will also
be at the Cloud Sandbox
with Google Cloud Storage
specific office
hours tomorrow afternoon.
Maybe check the schedule for the
exact time, and thank you
all very, very much
for coming.
BILL: Thank you.